when you first moved to Los Angeles what
was your strategy for finding work in
the film industry the first job I found
was on Facebook I think Facebook
I don't know if it's getting less so but
I think it's really great the groups for
just getting your foot in the door you
know and just responding and I was lucky
I um that like I just had the right gear
at the right moment and they just needed
somebody that day to show up for two
weeks and took a leap of faith and went
to this house I was like driving into a
place I've never been I'm gonna stay in
this cabin with these people and
hopefully I don't get murdered you know
and luckily it all worked out and once
you meet a couple people usually if you
do good good work and you have good
ethic and you're fun to be around and
people can tolerate you for 16 hours a
day you'll get hired again you know but
it is it is a lot of like personality
you know you can't
um be too needy or demanding or annoying
because like you're not gonna get the
work
um
so yeah this is just like getting the
first job out of the way and then just
responding
um a lot of my work actually comes from
film festivals so you know I bring my
work to a film festival and then I meet
other screenwriters and other directors
and suddenly like I'm on their mind to
call because I've seen my work and
they've met me we've gotten to be
friendly we make friends on Facebook or
social media and then they're like okay
maybe you can come shoot my movie um
when it's time so like a lot just
through General networking you know and
luckily like because
I think it would be would have been much
harder for me if I didn't have any body
of work when I first arrived in La
um but because I had three features
under my belt that I'd made on nothing
when nobody in Boston you know just like
our friends
um you know it showed that I had
something you know like to come with and
be like all right look like this is what
I can do you know hire me for whatever
um so I think that helped because I had
I tried to make those movies not knowing
how La Works
um it I think would have been a lot more
difficult you know now I probably could
now that I've met enough people and made
enough connections and I kind of
understand a little bit more how the
industry works here
um I've been able to make low budget
movies here but I think
just like diving in it would have been
much harder not having that
understanding so yeah so I guess it's a
lot of networking and uh talking to
people and getting out there responding
to ads
how does the industry work here versus
let's say Boston which is a major city
yeah uh well Boston has like the the big
movies that come from LA and shoot there
and then just people doing a very DIY
um so there's not like a lot in the
middle of like like the one million
dollar Indie type stuff you know or even
500 000 you know there's not a lot of
those movies being made there that I
know of
um so for me it was just like who's my
community I was friends with we're last
dancers poets musicians that's who I
casted my phones and they're great you
know
um you know people that were used to
putting their whole heart and soul out
on the stage like you know suddenly like
yeah I want to be in your movie you know
or I want to help with your crafty or
whatever you know so it was just like I
had that Community there and it was very
easy to get started just like pulling in
these people
um and then here I just think it's a
little more structured I guess like you
know you need this permit or like you
need this insurance and like uh you have
to have like a certain base level I
think of professionalism that
um I maybe didn't start with even though
we did have like insurance for our first
stuff
um
you know there's like a base expectation
I guess of how it's going to run and I
know there are people that do it without
that base expectation but you know it
gets a little sketchy and especially now
as a worker like I don't want to be on
sets where there's not like a base level
of professionalism because you get
abused very quickly uh in whatever way
you know time food money you know all
that stuff
um so you want to see like a base level
like okay did they have insurance do
they have a payroll whatever
um so yeah I don't know I think it's
just like not having the the community
yet it was more it and now I have it a
little bit more like I know a lot of
crew I can call you know we all work
pretty cheap for each other you know and
our corporate rates are much different
than our friend rates and you know so
like you build up your friends
it was the same thing it's just like
it's
still a little bit more structured I
guess
and this Facebook group was this like a
Mandy type thing or no this was
different this was like a Facebook group
that was about filmmaking yeah it has
like a very generic I don't even
remember the exact group it had a very
generic name like film crew needed Los
Angeles or something like that you know
I'm sure I'm still in the group if it
still exists
um but yeah it was definitely like a
very generic name and there's like a
whole bunch you can join um you know I'm
in one for I don't do reality television
I'm not opposed to it but I'm in like a
woman in reality television group where
people are very helpful with each other
and with the resources and ideas and
things there are like a lot of different
different little groups where people are
trying to find each other
yeah I think it's better like I did try
Mandy and some of them were websites but
I think like for whatever reason
Facebook you can just click on the name
see kind of what they're about you know
before you respond how about Craigslist
because you can find some decent stuff
there right do you still I don't know if
you still but I know that you could
either find horrible things or like
really like wow this person's actually
really cool and they're legit it's not
you know but knowing is the tough part I
think yeah being able to vouch for the
person back in the early 2000s my first
Craigslist ad for a Band-Aid was like PJ
needs the bad seeds and that was my ad
and I one person responded and he was
amazing and so like that was my one like
good experience with Craigslist for a
drummer it's like this one ad I put out
and the you know the Inner Space of
whatever the interwebs
um but I've never gone to it for crew
for since then for like film crew I feel
like I'd be a little scared about who
would show up laughs do you remember
your first paid filmmaking job here in
LA
uh yeah uh I think I was making like
fifty dollars a day I was out in the
woods it was we were all staying in this
cabin
um but yeah I definitely wasn't paid
minimum wage I think I got was like 500
bucks for like the two weeks and it was
like all right I'll just go on the
adventure definitely like if there's an
adventure involved like for me sometimes
that's more than like whatever money is
involved and like all right this sounds
crazy I might die let's go
um but yeah and that led into
um the next feature I did out here was
in uh
oh my God what's Roswell New Mexico it
was like another thing like okay you're
gonna get in this car with these people
and
they're gonna take you to another state
you know and so like definitely
there's things that could have turned
into bad experiences I guess you know
like leaps of Faith but um
you know they were fine
I wouldn't say I was treated that great
on some of them or that I was paid when
I should have been on any of them but
you know it's all learning experiences
so knowing that like okay these are the
terms and this is also for the
experience it's not just like because
you know as people are younger they're
like I need to be paid and that makes
sense people should be paid but
kind of like earning your stripes yeah
but being paid at the same time right
yeah I mean I guess you know they always
say that like you need to work for free
or whatever I don't think you should
ever work for free I think that's bad
and so like I always try to pay at least
minimum wage for even the lowest jobs
you know like I think like that's the
law in California and it's also the
right thing to do you know it's a very
expensive state to live in and I believe
that our minimum wage should be higher
you know
um but in my own life yeah I'll work for
whatever if I think it's fun you know
that's just how I structured my life but
um
you know just to get your foot in the
door at least smaller Productions they
don't have a lot of money it's very
expensive like you know crew is the bulk
of your cost always
um so yeah if you want to have that
experience you want to take those gigs I
think that's okay and you'll learn a lot
about what not to do usually
do you think that you were comfortable
going on the quote-unquote adventure
because you toured with bands
maybe yeah maybe you know you get
um a certain sense of self in a certain
sense of
um being able to work with people and
collaborate and get through anything
like I think one of the greatest things
about film for me is like if I don't
like somebody in two weeks I don't ever
have to work with them again you know
and if I do like them like I remember
them and I try to like be friends and
and come on each other's projects you
know so it's like you're collecting the
good trading cards and you're like
dropping the ones that are not as good
um but yeah you know I can get through
two weeks with anybody pretty much you
know uh probably because of music
for you into some I mean were there some
situations where it was like dicey where
you'd know if you had a place to stay or
whatever with different band setups or
you know whether you're going to get
paid or whether you know bar owner or
whatever was going to you know stiff you
on the money or oh yeah certainly you
know like money disappears in clubs like
you know certainly play gigs were like
they passed the hat around and then it
disappears you know like where did it go
um but yeah you know there's always some
sketchiness I think anything where it's
considered fun for you then suddenly you
know it doesn't matter to people if if
you get paid or not you know
um so yeah you're gonna watch yourself a
little bit but you know I always had
other side hustles so it's like if one
gig falls through like I'm not gonna be
out on the street that gig you know but
if every gig falls through it's gonna be
a problem
um yeah but yeah certainly you know like
I like
if I trust whoever's bringing me on and
they don't have a lot of information
I'll go with the flow you know but if
it's a stranger at this point like yeah
I need to know where I'm staying you
know give me the address let me look it
up you know show me a contract and all
that stuff but I have a friend who hires
me all the time I get a location and a
time I don't get a call she whatever I'm
like okay but we're friends so like I
know at least like you're gonna look out
for me you know even if the production's
not we've got each other you know
how are you able to find so much work
here now
um most of my work comes from networking
at this point just from knowing people
um I probably should put myself out
there to Blind ads a little bit more
it's just not my personality so much but
yeah through referral at this point and
through people I meet you know just I
have so much work out there I shoot a
lot of short films and films for other
people that then go off on the festival
circuit so my name is always like kind
of circulating a little bit
um but yeah it's so it's just mostly
through friends at this point
do you ever worry is
is does it ever occur to you like what
if the work's not there next month or
you just kind of trust that it's going
to show up it feels very seasonal
honestly because like there's always the
beginning of the year I always have like
nothing January February like like am I
ever gonna work again you know and
especially when I first came out to LA
like when I first hit those I was like
oh no like it's over nobody has any work
like I gotta figure out how to put
myself out there more but my Summers
always get insane from like May to
September I work a lot uh I don't know
why that is especially on the Indie
level like I think on like the more
Union level where you're doing Pilots
there's always pilot season it has more
of a seat like its own season I don't
know why on the Indie level summers are
always really busy for me but that's
been the case every year that I like
kind of make it up in that middle chunk
of the year and then it dies down around
November again
um but yeah so it's just like kind of
trusting the seasonal aspects of it a
little bit even though I don't
understand why they happen other than
like holidays and stuff
um but yeah something always comes
around eventually
yeah la does seem to kind of close down
right around I mean I know Halloween
isn't part of the holidays but it almost
seems like into the holiday season if
you want to call it October 31st or
whatever it seems like La shuts down a
little bit yeah I love how spooky it
gets in LA in December when everybody
leaves because so much of us are
transplants here so like everybody goes
home and it's so quiet like Hollywood
Boulevard you could go shoot whatever
you want there's nobody there
um I love that time like so I I almost
never go home for the holidays because I
just like how quiet it is here
how much do you have to prioritize
getting paid to work on other people's
projects versus doing your own
um I think it just comes down to
scheduling for me you know like I'll
schedule my own projects if I know ahead
of time I'm gonna be working on somebody
else's thing let's schedule my own stuff
for later you know
um so a lot of freelance is just keeping
your schedule in its rains and stuff
changes constantly it drives me crazy
um yeah I don't think it's like I need
to
totally choose ever I try to make time
for everything
um
but you know like in my work like
for a feature or whatever if I have two
weeks to shoot or whatever over X period
of months like I can find those days
that are always working around whatever
other work I have because I'm the one
planning those so I can decide when they
are uh so I don't think it's a choice so
much but yeah there always needs to be
some work coming in
was that part of your plan to always
have some time for your own projects for
the two of you yeah I mean I know that
they say like hey if you get a job in
reality TV you might make great money
but then it may be harder to get your
own stuff made because you're so bound
with these schedules yeah
um yeah definitely somebody was asking
me recently if I wanted to go into
reality I'm like I don't know that I
want to work every day for six months
you know like because I need my down
time and physically like you know I'm
not the youngest anymore like there's
definitely a reason why you know a lot
of backbreaking work happens in your 20s
you know I'm getting a little bit older
and I don't want to be that like
damaging to my back and stuff like you
know carrying camera every day for
months and months and months like I can
do it for two weeks fine you do it for a
month fine but like when that there's no
end in sight no break in sight I don't
know if that's for me that's why I like
features where it's like you got a month
you got two months easy you take a break
you know
um
so yeah
I think it is always important for me to
have my own thing going because I need
to have control over something
in my life so I need to be the one like
you know if something's not right it's
my fault and that's fine and I can
accept that uh but at least like I am
the person trying the hardest you know
um
and then like you know you can go off
and work on whatever but you know I
always need something that's mine that's
cooking you know Brewing yeah because
some people make that decision early in
life or then sometimes maybe after they
have a successful corporate career you
know what I need time to do creative
stuff and that's the most important
thing over making money and I get it
when you have kids you can't make that
decision but
yeah I wasn't sure if maybe being
available to have projects or being able
to do whatever you want
was more of a
decision maker in what jobs you take oh
yeah um certainly yeah like for me it's
all about
um you know like that's why I like being
a director for photography because it is
creative you know and I do have a lot of
say in the project as a whole
um but other jobs and stuff that's just
filling in my schedule and I do it
because I've learned the skills you know
these are the skills I have now so I
might as well let them make me a little
bit money on this side you know but yeah
it's always about my own stuff that's
like what's the goal is I guess you know
is to be doing myself on a bigger and
bigger level my own projects uh and
everything else is is feeding into that
machine for me career-wise you know
um but yeah that's certainly the most
important thing always is the art and
what I'm doing
um but I have a lot of fun you know like
I like being an AC like I said like I
have a lot of fun doing it if the set's
good and the people are fun you know and
you're doing good work that's good
enough for me for that period of time
you know I can put the other stuff aside
for a month or two months or whatever
um but yeah there always needs to be
something that I'm working on in the
back burner